انا مع عائلتي احاول الهرب الى بر
[تصفيق]
الامان ابني يشعر
بالر
خافش خافش اقول له لا تخاف يا ب لا تخاف
لكن الحقيقه هي انا خائف
جدا اسمي ابراهيم دهمان انا صحفي في سي ان
ان ولسنوات عديده ساعدت في تغطيه قصص
الناس في غزه لكنني لم اكن اظن ابدا انني
ساصبح جزء من القصه افتح افتح السياره يوم
الاثنين الماضي كنت في الرمال في مدينه
غزه عندما طلب مني
الاخلاد اطلع على اول حاجه على شو اسمه
ولكن اين اذهب
فبيتي وعائلتي وحياتي كلها في الرمل مثل
كثيرين غيري ليس لدي اي مكان اخر اذهب
اليه وصلنا الى الفندق قريب هناك صحفيون
وعائلات وحتى اشخاص
بمفرده نحن الان جزء من النازحين بين اكثر
من مليون شخص طلب منهم اخلاء شمال
غزه بصفو شو اسمه بصفو الفنادق صح بتفو
الفنادق لا اعلم في قراره نفسي انه لا
يوجد مبنا امن نشاهد الغارات الجويه من
نافذه
الفندق وصوت الانفجارات يبقينا مستيقظين
في
الليل
ا يا
راسي
في يومنا الثالث شاهدت مبنى مجاورا يتعرض
لضربه جويه
اخرى كان هناك رجل وقع في مرمى
النيران لاحظت انه ابن عم
والدي والحمد لله انه اصيب بجروح طفيفه
فقط انا لازم لازم اتحرك من الفندق لانه
الوضع كثير
صعب
نقوم بتحميل سيارتنا المتض بكل ما لدينا
من ممتلكات ونتجه جنوبا الى خانيونس
بعد ما طلعنا من الفندق يعني
ثواني ضربوا صاروخ او برميل خرب المنطقه
كلها نحن الان في خان يونس وبالرغم من ان
الغارات الجويه مازالت مستمره الا اننا
نشعر بامان اكثر هنا وانها مساله وقت
فقط ولكني امل ان نتمكن يوما من العوده
الى
ديارنا